take a look at this password how long do
you think it would take a hacker to
crack it 60 seconds 30 minutes 5 hours a
week the correct answer is 34 years why
this password incorporates the necessary
characteristics for resistance it's
eight characters long and contains four
types of symbols to crack such a
password one would need to attempt 6.6
quadrillion combinations even if the
password is being attempted at a rate of
6 million per second it still amounts to
1.1 GP billion seconds although same 34
years but is it possible to create a
password that no one can crack watch our
new video about Brute Force to find out
the
answer